[Music]
nothing is so beautiful about the brand channel on this
site is that the big day village
forms public consultancy for details and big
data and turkey in the shutter work at
klm air france klm
and in it your server projects such as
product in normal fernand passengers
were to built it but with it
presentation coloration with jan van der
vegt third scientist at klm
a strong liang can manage right i have
the go-to we go for a business trip
corian will be meant for my
home and one note is box questions
please  25 the branches
ok let's start something like talcum powder old
problem that refreshing gentleman you live your
products number or r-line passengers the
name or passengers that want to board is
specific flight
and so here again for timeline who has
a flight the wild horse and the certain
point in time and at some point you want
to do's of planning you need a plan your
resources ei you want to see for
instance you want to know how many
people will board at flight have you
kra  cht and you can you stuff like
revenue management may the lower on the
prices ticket you can do
supply chain optimization management the
french to see how many mails sent
buddha board is flight
and gay mail super juice and you can use
our user to allocate your resources
furniture  van dave van time for distant
crashed chat where there are more use cases and
was interesting of this this case is
that you fg yes there can the many more
flights that de part
this point time points what you live you do
your schedule and several
fixed point before  departure you will
not be able to basic you for cabinet she
mounts or pêcheurs
constantly her rijssense this makes
the label knew about the glasgow
forecasting is anyway one to the guys
in this chain narrow on the garden
zo this blink sauce adds to requirements
of this this dit is die cities signs use
case and if you want to build system at
free to deliver search for cost
first of all we want the website for
upcoming flys is the most importa  nt ones
you know how many people
overboard shackly want de doe dat en
someone who long for departure and preferably
in distress fixed point not like two
weeks before but maybe two comma six
weeks before but also for hours before
departure and of course you won't  have
occurred for closet because what if I put it
in it and they laugh or add nuances to
the talk about that
bit more in the tail leather so as the
system design and this is very simple
of drivers and fight so cbf
sunfly unless booking deta becomes the  poot intu
war machine learning holder for casting
system and then it out boots for
specific flight the amount of
passengers that will likely board is
flight
yes simple with the with kon notation because
the finder' function f of the time for
influence feature sex and just be to  my
target de the number passenger stats
counter board at the waist of this talk
is this is carnival siteur designer
machine learning such a fancy what are you doing
mimi bed and have a look inside
yes who mime  i dat measurements customize and
rhythm using them an oled during
structure and the use case requirements to
basic limitée en machine learning uhm
that is taylor to this use case and will
see how we go it took a little more
love in follows tuning die inputs and
also what u want he issued moodle
but how get clearing deliver so be that
we've made and artificial light booking
did set week and of use the whale did
van calais en for this but were also
working on al die step i swear at klm
hoe  want to share your medical advice said you
sing arnold each of the domain
and there who has the timeline and om the
timeline who has is booking in fans
or cancellation that guy and dab this
click will and lift the partner that gives you
the final a month or  people that left
bij porn and maybe you can so luc
ardies list cancellation say people
that don't show had tess or something in a
gate effect er in zwolle
plate and then moment or planning wie of
course i don't know the entire
f  uture of is this guy so that office
hour and then was just ensar target would
the moon of people that will actually
board is flight and why you look at this
shows and would you see to die xaxis
de de horses total en om de wimax a
sicilian  simple instagram i see that
there mire and worry free never go
that is want for complex de verburg and
who
putins around it and distant anger who
lives money fashion or would the model s
disappoint knows that that a and the not even
is amazing for that old site  die
input features will be left there i can
fly dh
booking dh we can make our simple
time-based features last searches the the
a month or days before departure of
we german soldiers at where the location
and it as so far imported wangen the
airline this is  we is so and
intercontinental flight
we are departure stationed at centers
where our jury statistics of facebooking
events don't keep me bookings vans to
heaven till now and harmony
cancellations die  n of links
and if you look at one of those seems the
inspection booking nr zodus is cumulative
a month of bookings meines de de
cancellations
and then i see that if i plot I
agree these scans the partner here we de
flip tex access to make  a tear
and so serious departure maybe
you make the booking and bring crisis and then
if you class on this
x-access you get is target dead is your
blousend somewhat
anyway and weekend also the van of
the morocco and church villages features that's
how they keep during  it's nice when
wfr flights something pro who has something
features always that partner departure
and and and for smart days the horses
toto
first-rate for it I would use this
to image men
11 crust is this is this is for an idea
the site is  the waynes call who is not to
do is the small areas graphic and
process so give in the month of bullying
century continues value different type
dictates leds duration 2 is the shapes
give longer know it samovar inputs this
park is like  there
target and what flexibility we go
it aquatic gave models in the neural
network at my die castein
weekend do the saws maybe learn
and customize the input output sweet
new network life is like a dance
floor even for can do it so dirty
list is now  al network here again for
output
thickening at the merkel features
weekend pick the least www
akiko features week and van had a goddess
and and who who who basically learn a
great bitez it me alone in moodle
in this model that simply candy simple
extended to your  feet for the poor
network where you ca
k so can the fans date layers in die
3230 en nesselande not very dries
non-linear activation functions and this
case it is also a fine output an ass
atma expressive in simple line your
men als our small  emergency so for the
church also known on bicycles poodles and
bedding symmetry
google talk about bethlehem i bigger so
i want to share
the past or so keep trainers and
save
how you have you d  e final of function and
one good starting point
mean square teller
ict de défense between art production
and the app will be square wit
wie effort [ __ ] that's why has grown to
minimize is zo has this is already loose
landscape i want to find busy  lead at
punishment in the in looked into the lens when
network printers a theory
cat summer of hopefully global minimum
and keep anyone who already does who
out of the using back corporation sowie der
troops give the air war signal' asked the
layers and then we  can train so this
number network when we have stable
could always help fire
ok so keep luke and cold muse and kira
very beacause watching high level 0
network lazy 3 picture on hand and she faint
and all bek and me a weasley coach at
this the  scoan of algorithms
zoey definer there input layers of first
and then i phone is to their readers to
this and and repeated brushing single
single like a shows in three in the evil
and den is meant is wc ok poverty for
whom d  e fine it comes
takes 4 inputs in plots and this from
trial lesson output and with it can compile
it in the clothes de los functionality
the thief old the military and and in
optimizer
success aggression teacher reads so chemistry
training tool we see that it can be
successful i  learned the bait would be
flat for a month the front cabinet the
amount of passengers of that xaxis in
the park toto to the truth is we china
is
seems own online with shunned most
between the modal can learn something
about the stage
what this doesn'  t say if she leaves
everything outside nice business value of
this a what we are going to do i slept white and
before who knows who so i can
sample simple use case the
smart simplify your inner use this for
cheese to add gates resources
it  suppose to be has a handshake
flights
and who has ninety 5 aircraft this can have
curry to their tea the passengers
place and there is who and lazy for his
overbooking i have football or
no show z like again  e in certain flight
and cancellations how je lovers
transfer who you 5 your uneven
5 and 2 door more than to repay the
people and but luckily
wie there five fat aircraft that i
once kind you python
journalists question common use these
conditions to  every ethical lost five years
and a nice weekend and do
why you because excelease mono the
be the try that is issue
is is is i see this so the the podiums
ok then what do you do you can a
computer proportion or correct  lee and
ok so
mountain both mean who bring color
flights this is you and for bunch of
flights who has is probability
wiringkit would just with the highscore
gracie sun till it cetra and then i see
in were out xlii was
bullied that overflow we work more
than to energy that were willing to go
bord is flight
dame je look en there top 5 lucas vr5
reserves aircraft
om him bridge and who computer pc how
much were correct would a this example
you know you where  the five for ar simple
model we show it out which the
expectation i this is 3 x-pect the
number fashion most expensive birth flight
what weekend silent rank all the flights
using that expectations so weekend i
do the simple i want you to know with whom
could her music from ermelo and density
a like and toe earth 5 if who are
never pencil case skeleton correct url ok the the
b church was
hassle this by random guessing you 5%
or lee
would this be so rogelli does good start for
simple ideas and what  kim I continue
and get so I hope and do and namely
to the talk about customizing the output
the men what we can do this week and
mobile the try that directly
basically and see what is
the province density function
about posible ruin a month  so
overboard is flight
and this creeper seal so dance the
death colt conventionally dance the
estimation
so high that the target is who can try to identify a
fine function that it was this entire
set of
justice ingo expectation
people with come home and defect and
the wall of a sure that why this my
target
polo's sun distribution and in this
example gone just use caution shofukan
is she is normal distribution
parameters at a new en sigma en des
conditions on her input  mr ex
zo i see you devos here who you would do of that
xaxis for instance a target space
then passions we drilled
flight en dewi see this dance that
functioning something point of wie or de
bossche bol target values ​​weekend bbq
pro inside tea
likely good  and since this with is new icd
in the chain got three location of
this box and week a writing dtv because
evie expect more and more pessimists
board and we the sigma week and control
scale of discussions on is best free the
certainty
is the fly  to go to be fully booked and you
can put me in this so I can use the logo
cook at lower
and out that you guys because freshly received
energy so I make it a blue someone
has something like that
what found is the [ __ ] you can not very
very handy week and quite
straightforward lee compute die exec
promobility on the product it probe the
idea who it is capacity overflow
to just some al die yes integrate everywhere
the rims set and barked live
retie
and the  header picasso and cancel passenger
parents this nice in architecture when
who java rapper architecture and
lightweight rievalie what well who do you have
outputs in stars of two outputs and
that sarah and new and a sigma and so
6 we go the product is now in the sigma
and  dad en per match eyes is out
conditional density function well do it
shane so network who has to make some
small 2 free know the third loose
functions such we are not going to do that
blowing square anymore the cosby de
kennels contern and tardis future  dance
the function want to bully single value picasso
not on server one single valley the in
excel moon by stiffness by
the do you have something else
computer likely y  ou and take the one like
of time and tanks my one and try to
minimize time so what's the minus in like
graphic love pectus here who does
n't have a target space
my name is see i look this was who
surfed for months fashion their share  my
and that indicate her life-blood so the
one to basically lift bed and boring spots
alone your man of because then it is
really good go into the product many
people going to fly and or by die
abortion flight of course it won't be
possible in  all situations to get
something like that sound en de molen is
county if we learn how insert it is
weekend on the myfritz
using and only maximize your
destination so in account huislook
when we can use the cooler bag flow
distribution object
so have i imported normal des
fire in the if much you suffer there keep you
see here that we do a first app
is defined is new and the sigma as
output distress and who connect and to my
final hit de leijer nice show before
and then i just put together  a kalkara
meters dessart final output leader en
den wie said a input would be cities path
that output will be this per myth layer
en der colostrum very fiercely defined is apart
of grace how that time called the los
function in times if you know custom good
in  the custom seperate from you said and did cake
is the true labels es first input and
your model output en sting input and
with that i can make 10 start this
music en tent road and into this normal
object of test flow decisions
wrap this object this weekend  normally
lord
lessons function or message pencil prop
and video by true is an input weekend
basically the likely you today value
and it's not zou easy over most
wet kind of difficult to make this
year's yourself men uw wat doing it like
this de thenns upload is  amazing on
sex true implemented intensive loco
something true efficient and you can use all
rise of operation get very creative wit all
those stip solutions and many more than the
standards that finally come per
c  ompiler models using this custom apart
from their and the optimizer internet
would you up to your own week i have i want you to
know this is the amazing
that for shows to be so boring because is get
one of lock
extensions to the man already so instead of
kenige single ganja week and so
women in
couples more to this end parents and child a
mixer of those two and that allows you
to get a lot more expressive
during the function as a few muddle and
fastest correct normal distribution
so we do this if i wanted to  that only
thing you after doe is this more notes so
beautiful muse beautiful chic maas and us of
purple and purple is best love nothing lost
a third this determines basically
hack so this area its looks
symbolized me for disco of class klier
and mick student networking  at
beach club so holders this network
perform wifi first would gathering
test moment came lift can previous video
naughty must de seagull i get to value of
has a digicode density we get more
levels di  e
and locations correct would you see that it
can learn a lot more about a propos
that is interesting
o'right became ciel jeans wit is approach
first is selecting is an output
distribution to shochu is your single
cross and example and if we dissolution the mixer
what you can get you can do
all opportunities excel text off you can also
use person distributor mixer or
person would mix or person singa
something I want you xlii so wet this
challenge reward importunities you box
can also in chorus greater love domains
let's
in  this in this out more distribution
cushion recognize left left passenger
board site and can sign discrete
try distribution
a recognize guts more of your or less
of european sustainable northern the mex
capacity then can sign finite for
which this shows and that oblique or domain
if i  him putin toe is your levels
output or you a mix of molle
that risk cross the choice and lord just
to make the bit more more more simple what
you can do  alkaline cool stuff and
us would be optimization what can help
is bit more tricky den de destiny
script error if you like blood is well oh
in a shirt and dijxhoorn
word or just too high internet also to
our it but just unemployment the lok
of sorrow and  that's probably kill
scheltema say oh right now we can
look at the input since final battle is
the city that cheese who have such a structure
in the input time have actually hef
cycle die ta we can expect more in
count this features of the in the  two
quick protest and to get this takes
continuously windows of
in history or facebooking sequence
would we go the time the vending machine
cancellations in this window this window
and who can schlucken the booking at
the channel engineer already chance of this
feature xlii above us  goal and that steal
woman my fate of information we must
want to do is to learn extra critical
statistics and praying for internet
sound and subject synthesis learning sui
did already hi  there with all the dark blue
leaders in it the credit series
leans xlii eta specific web are
signs for input data that helps as
predictor
assessed passengers and this can or
trick is we would succeed bolte sequence
deta it is summarize when flying
sequence in 2007 grab  synthesis
old judith yes that said the de mee duel
dan the kernel network zoey tail wit and
auntie
web synthesis vector u can a woman in
her bookings guy
this is basically media boolean
indicating with the she bookings
cancellation and with the d's for the
partner fruit into  this architectures we
can already network architecture and
longshirt and memory sell for instance
am
update we learned the wraps and tation
woman in the next event
using the previews robson tation s it is
second input so i would like them update
the web are against or  the entire history
of the sequence
yes and then moby do who here
again arm bar' er rond architecture and
adjust
conquete nate plugin dit web synthes  e
it the next to your other input
i discovered a product and that
scarification can contain if it is
since the district council you month or
let the booking great order de total the
cumulative month
bar zip bag i realize and is learn for
jota always really great
during look and cold I would add an input
simply the hell svm layer end and the
fine new input chic us input
plugin to record player den merge it
again there other input and then image poor
network of there can be the mixer
densities kempi miezko terror whatever
you want the fine it seems this
wind engine input comes palette
then in her simulations
housework so on which you will now
happily sequential videos from the
chic wish and if we use the rumen means of
course to some be cooked up in the
simulation animals miner test point of
which  you have above the the input and the
output und you know or cost best the best
model would be lift the home correct
challenges owh spring is that actually who
has to uniform t  ent airtime deltas
bikinis events die cellist em more
spectacular you at lee designs
for getting
b-circuit and regular intervals peist en
je die fans in fact is not no title
deal
luckily the already en livia de is called the big
bang king al would de cel  already
time before departure inputs out knows
how far we from the portuguese and the
kempic clients correctly for so that
's our alternative like party lsd am
doing convolution soap attention leyers
many many stuff i in their second
challenge is to incorporate flight de
pens cissé en  reservations country but the
vlm driver instinct round has the
couple if you read can get this the
cram gates peritoneum show this
is fly so connect the ideal flight and
they had flights the members i netherlands
train tracks passengers this billboard
f-lite you will how  all of that has
spoil the chain den and so pray or yes i
can also try to get this schedule
information in your mobile
so a crap convolut  ion soave a cool
stuff lots to explore so far exciting
something like that and yet the tight and the khiter
quasar basically
a lot a show that i can use domains
let's share scripture
and the use case requirements to get is
taylor machine learning solutions
secondly your compliance density
estimation technical  to get en wat beautiful
information a review graph and
output en you can that specialized
network architecture such as the return
your network to summarize and merge the
sequential detail interior flat
features basically zo
jazz de final nood working at air france
klm
we have centralized ede  sized
apartment with a ladder tip of
products itself
yes the live view and very cool big
detail warming and did signs community
we training's workshop so effective
winters this preece contact banner from
the group manager we death and like to
add thank you for your attention is so
and that matter
[Applause]
yes yes sorry questions were interested in
this example use case to eager  om de
try buttocks tee of this capacity
overflow
and we do who directly moodle so
try it i like free the classifier
of you since
overflow yes or no one's here
yes you can do that and that might also
give you could we blame that I
der  sidewalk art and their first is this
for the simplicity of this example a your
girlfriend in this way we can imagine that
is not only to know what our other
values ​​that you had written a festival
beautiful don't let more information
and you not the two and  let more
classifiers do the same for the
simplistic or is this the stuck the ex
empel glass for my work but in reality
you might have more complex situation
where you do has the entire dance team
and us surf or multiple clients and
then i use case is for the passenger
for closet
sign already used at density in their own
de oompa kuurpark user do you know on
most process where that good question
tank and have sucked at the microphone and
thank you for interesting tak  and to
let you digibuddy cheese and [ __ ] models
out then became them in the past and
classical worry fashion setting and and
wise pound and was that me a pager
I find in grams of getting stuck in
local minimal twisted the door mixer
russian against
carl all  baby's earring and was curious
had workstyle in practice in
molenbeek at the circus
now under workshop and the famous for not
actually have to worry sooo much about
local minnema hold on and wonder this
out
yes de where a good question so we
really on purpose those people do  the
optimization excuse now i have this so i
can do it networks in the simulation is
then the problem
what may be related to your question is
what you can give us once the
thick side or mixer molenwei usa ok and
then a fix all discussions and  there we
the fix neil
when you a dpd her space a long
great around your waist texas and then
count on the corn oil that already or dead
cheeses and this
kids bit more stable optimization mi
jn most license
that it is cool curl to excursions we
can join again dance the
estimation
yes we offer you now explore
frank
she let me nice enter room here you have
him dead
and here you have hands and use wax from
co2
get shuttle memories of you models
for the 5% and the fiftythree and everything
wondering how much time in advance black
all out war ow van die axel flight
artoos reasult lucas die ken i
imagine that you would like to know
we've seen at fans
hou  your flight schedule gonna be like and
arubanen oreo mails and stuff like that
sell more value that's ex-libris in
advance
well yeah yeah so on and so it is
so you empty me in the self this forge is
a sex symbol pups is for this  task
is you can on show I want percent it
is excel precise use case be
using here what your rider in the furry you
go wave at the departure moment the lukewarm
the performance is internal or so in this
passion for cabinet new ref position
is  this a performance  nce in quizjes the the
judgment
yes best love ever the crisis the the
cloud feel i get you the partner
so you become you do write network
for the overall performance or
win your own what that already so space star
out at this point
moments before departure  and ideal your
apps some kind or
know this some of our city by monsieur
fogg already public if it will measured such lesson or
problem so mistake
earlier to
me if you know then level offers wind'
infant flights tea light order bit
more more meals  for instance for
catering
16 days before the part your you have your
you can still use the other is a bottle of
oil at the site your level out but if
this might
and seven hours before departure and
that's that's can him plan that so
you know in advance  this costs from chevrolet
thank you so much your tassel all that surinamese
urchin he is so
ginger dust simple model to the mold
complex can push your other so that aydin
so that there are no chimp moments in them
exactly in
and so in one and the other  s knee it harder
to explain it is then more complex
mother and that via points jeep makes sense
in toe
yes system which when they perform and the
audio precision one percent increase
my
yes so good question would i know this is
was assimilation so google-  shirt week the
mr and the bit more than a point chaud
feature study did if you that we did
things defense so sour in the battle
what has this course the actual live
production dna and he must see this then
of course is one percent
mike less late  but you this for the
ezio no fun the test is kristin that
her students fine what is the case if
this false positive of this
and locating and aircraft just lead and
her to compensate mow bad luck time
kennel decent if that too racist
mall
when we already booked  for a correct
pay them but if you
and ok the piglets aircraft and its and and added
oil to the safty baby boy
birth has extra view
there are lot of business process after
that and edgy you  because heft medical
shepard project
to get insight into the sadistic cabinet
or something business and then see how your
mobile met series basically i also
translate to growth and then you can
willy answer this question take die
want patient caesar one million euros
per month and  then
also yes aggression yes come tanks for their
shock have pains white wash and so
lobith past is financial
audits
the 5% it's your camp sometime
start a workshop from other this can expert
judgment day cutting can take him into the reef
so  'n stands for doing forecasting
what is so for the simple xsample what
is what sticks do I already have starting
position that you computing events
yes so cool question
xlii now as if all benefits from jan de
naeyer bed and weekend you can now see that
the booking
number it is itself and deadline garden
mike di bello baseline profi
has the tools for sure simplicity
but i so that actually
and verycook baseline to bounce stab
de waal b  oeking number bright and then
if you want to do something more complex
you already getting into duel of linear
regression ethics and thus an expert
smoothing men on the sky no thanks is
nice to an industry you draw
previous flight it was like the same
flight
wat  under those points d
here you see my iq la fere how many
people who share us mother de bat de der
tuin or baseline los because you do the
booking number and
smoothing expression smoothing and
then i get into the room of regression
sorry put the booking
number and youth i try to a little
extra quality this yes yes that is
kind of in this context for klm contexts
your channel talk about that but in this
context ruffles simulation thankgiving
ok we him time for my final tassel yes
sorry or can krishna what simulation
detail
attributing it is the wall
limit she really is that crazy so my question is is
twitter wheel
dating i have battery battery sales
to what you getting better and sing  you
like more
well anyway marker set so let's test
symbolic for who i sample what
influence who this is the whole verbal that
is not fred i am arlberg baby splits is
distribution
between an early flights and francis
live live it fly late in the evening
wit  based on a knowledge from the
melange have to date where of course we
cannot tell you exactly
and taste people in patients tjes for
klm die concessions reaction and chief
information that
yes sorry is the first in this
distribution twitter never put it
where son jan played  around and logical
ricardo wesenbeeck I die siebe Lievens
be something like that to this
ok yes ok thanks everyone for your
questions
eventhough alexander was not able to
give you all the precise
josina  ]